ومنزله
العلماء
متميزه بكل ما
تعني اتدرون
لماذا
لانهم ورثه الانبياء عليهم الصلاه
والسلام فلذلك
لا بد لنا ان نوقر
الامام الامام العالم
العامل
لانه ممثل عن حضره النبي صلى الله عليه
واله وصحبه
وسلم فاعلموا يقينا ايها الاخوه ان من
يوقر
العالم والامام
العامل بذلك قد عظم ووقر حضره النبي صلى
الله عليه واله وصحبه
وسلم وقد جاء لفظ الائمه
والامام في القران الكريم في مواضع
عده لما لهم من منزله رفيعه وعظيمه عند
الله
تعالى
ورسله عليهم الصلاه
والسلام قال الله
تعالى وجعلناهم ائمه يهدون
بامرنا واوحينا اليهم فعل
الخيرات واقام الصلاه وتا
الزكاه وكانوا لنا
عابدين وقال سبحانه
وتعالى ونريد ان نمن على الذين استضعفوا
في الارض ونجعلهم ائمه ونجعلهم
الوارثين وقال تعالى وجعلنا منهم ائمه
يهدون بامرنا لما
صبروا وكانوا باياتنا
يوقنون وقال تعالى واذ ابتلى واذ ابتلى
ابراهيم ربه بكلمات
فاتمهن قال اني جاعلك للناس
اماما قال ومن
ذريتي قال لا ينال عهدي
الظالمين وقال سبحانه وتعالى افمن كان على
بينه من ربه ويتلوه شاهد منه ومن قبله ومن
قبله كتاب موسى اماما
ورحمه اولئك يؤمنون
به وقال عز وجل والذين يقولون ربنا هب لنا
من
ازواجنا
وذرياتنا قره اعين واجعلنا للمتقين اماما
فال الائمه في
اللغه من يقتدى بهم من رئيس او
غيره ومفرده
امام ولا يبعد المعنى الاصطلاحي عن المعنى
اللغوي باطلاقه الشامل لمقتدى بهم عموما
في مجال الخير والشر طوعا او كرها هذا ما
ذكره الامام التفت ازاني رحمه الله في
العقيده
النسفيه
وكذلك يطلق لفظ
الائمه على الانبياء عليهم الصلاه
والسلام انهم ائمه من حيث يجب على الخلق
اتباعهم قال تعالى عقب ذكر بعض الانبياء
عليهم الصلاه السلام
وجعلناهم ائمه يهدون
بامرنا كما يطلق على الخلفاء
الراشدين
ائمه
لانهم رتبوا في المحل الذي يجب على الناس
اتباعهم وقبول قولهم
واحكامهم وتوصف امامتهم بالامامه
الكبرى كما
يطلق لفظ الائمه على الذين يصلون
بالناس وتقيد هذه
الامامه وتسمى بالامامه
الصغرى لان من دخل في
صلاتهم
لزمه الاتمام
بهم قال عليه الصلاه
والسلام انما جعل الامام ليؤتم به فاذا
ركع فاركعوا واذا سجد
فاسجدوا ولا تختلفوا على
امامكم عن ابي هريره رضي الله عنه قال قال
رسول الله صلى الله عليه واله وصحبه
وسلم
المؤذن مؤتمن اي مؤتمن على
الوقت والامام ضامن اللهم ارشد
الائمه واغفر للمؤذنين
اللهم اجعلنا ائمه
صادقين وارثين واجعلنا من العلماء
العاملين هداه هاديين مهديين واستغفر الله
العظيم لي ولكم ولوالدي ولسائر المسلمين
اجمعين ادعوا الله وانتم موقنون
بالاجابه